Sure, thanks Mark.
My name is Jimeng Sun.
I'm Associate Professor at the College Computing in
the School of Computational Science and Engineering.
And prior to Georgia Tech,
I was a research staff member at IBM T.J. Watson Research Center for six years.
Sure.
So, EHR data really
has many challenges if you want to build analytics model using those data.
So number one is the messiness and unreliable information in those data sources.
So oftentimes, some information about patient are
not recorded and they're only recorded during the visit,
which are very sparsely scattered over time.
So, we don't know what actually happened in between two different visit.
So, a lot of the information are not in the data.
And whenever they are in the data,
they're not all accurate.
Some diagnosis could show up but that doesn't mean the patient have the disease.
They may just come in for screening but the code still show up for billing purpose.
So, you can't really trust the data a lot.
Sorry, you can't really trust the data all the time,
so you have to really leverage many other different way to figure out those information
is reliable or not.
Sure. So, for EHR data,
it has many different sources.
Such as, in the structure field,
you have diagnosis code, medication, lab results.
Then you have unstructured field.
Those are clinical notes,
often times are dictated or entered by clinicians or nurses directly.
So, many people actually think that unstructured clinical notes
consists of most reliable information that clinicians put in,
and all the other information such as
diagnosis code and other things are derived from there.
I mean, unstructured data itself is very messy.
Again, it's not really a well drafted article that people can read and understand,
it consists a lot of acronyms and the sentences are very short.
It's really those unstructured data serve as a note for
the clinicians themselves so next time the patient comes
back they can remember what happened in the previous visit.
So, how can we extract useful information directly from that noisy,
unstructured form, it's very challenging.
So, the way we do it is leveraging two source of information.
One is, there are a lot of medical oncology
that researchers have built up over the years.
So, that tells us what different spelling of the word
means and acronyms means in the clinical documents.
So, we use oncology to help us to extract a lot of clinical concepts directly,
so that we can map those very diverse set of mentions
of clinical concept into a consistent concept ID.
Then the second way we're dealing with unstructured information is,
leveraging the core occurrences of all those mentions.
When two medical concepts co-occur in a clinical document,
especially if they are very close by in the same sentence or same paragraph,
oftentimes they are related.
So, we leverage that co-occurancy information to help us to derive the relationship
of those medical concepts.
Sure. So, as you probably have described in your previous class.
I mean CHF is very important condition and many things can lead to heart failures,
and it's very challenging to predict the onset of heart failure earlier.
And the way we're approaching that is,
we integrate all source of information about patients from their EHR,
then construct diverse set of features that characterize the patient representation.
Then use those features and trying to correlate those features to the outcome,
which is whether the patient has a CHF or not.
And then build a predictive model,
leveraging all those different diverse set of features.
So, this is a standard predictive model pipeline.
It has two different phases,
the customization phase and the standardization phase.
So, the customization phase involves extracting features from raw data.
In this case, the raw data can come from structure EHR such as diagnosis, medical, sorry,
the structured data can come from diagnosis code,
medications, and lab results and unstructured EHR are usually those clinical notes.
And there's two different ways to extract features,
either you directly map those structured variables into features,
or you have to do some natural under
processing from the unstructured data to extract that features.
Once you have those features,
you can put all of them together,
then the downstream modeling is pretty much standard.
And you take all those features,
and trying to figure out which one are predictive to your final target, for example,
if you want to predict onset of heart failures,
only the features that are relevant for predicting heart failure will be included.
So, the feature selections that will remove most of the irrelevant features.
Finally, you have a classification model
to map the relevant feature to the outcome to make the final prediction.
The performance of the predictive model usually come from the quality of the features.
If the feature are predictive,
then the model will be good.
So, here's just one example showing the impact of different type of features.
And the Y-axis is the performance score in terms of area under the curve,
so, the higher the better.
And the X-axis is the number of feature you included in your model.
So, we start with a set of domain,
or we start with knowledge driven feature.
Those are the features such as co-morbidities that are relevant to heart failure.
And, you can see if you only include those features,
the performance is about 60%,
slightly above 60% of accuracy.
And then after that,
if you used a data driven features,
such as the feature selection asset,
then trying to find
all the relevant features that potentially predictive to heart failure,
you can see a huge jump in terms of performance from about 0.62-0.7 or above.
And more features you included,
it become more predictive.
Sure. So, in the past, or even now,
it's pretty standard to follow the process of taking the data,
then based on your domain knowledge and your understanding of the data,
to construct a set of features that are really meaningful to a domain experts probably,
then trying to figure out a way to correlate those features to the final outcome.
In this case, heart failure or no heart failure.
But the challenge for those approach is,
you have to understand what features are relevant
to begin with in order to extract those from data.
But the challenge is,
for heart failure for example, in that setting,
not all the predictive features are known to the clinician or to the domain expert.
So, it's very hard to manually create all those features.
And the new approach we're taking,
we're using deep newer network or
deep learning approach that directly model the raw data,
that as long you know EHR data,
those events sequences, both structured data and unstructured data.
And the algorithm, those deep learning models,
will automatically extract and construct a feature and then correlate that with outcomes.
So, we don't have to provide those feature in an ad hoc basis.
Now, the algorithm can figure out those features by themselves. Thank you.